a pet dog has been rescued after she was
led to safety by a drone armed with a
sausage millie who's a jack russell
cross had gone missing when she escaped
from her lead on a walk in heaven in
hampshire after a search that lasted
several days she was eventually located
on mudflats but with the tide coming in
and no way to access the area rescuers
came up with a novel way to coax her
towards a safety they dangled a sausage
from a drone to tempt her back well
denmead drones search and rescue were
behind the cunning plan and i'm joined
now by sarah kane uh who is one of their
first responders i'm so sorry is it
sarah or sarah
it's sad sorry sarah kane lovely to have
you with us uh first things first who
came up with the idea
of dangling a sausage off a drone that
can't be a normal operation for you
uh no it was definitely very much a last
resort and it was one of our drone
pilots
who came up with the idea we know that
dogs do respond well to high-value
treats
and we were kind of at our wit's end
really about how we could get
millie off the mud flats
when yeah our drone pilot dave suggested
that perhaps a sausage attached to the
drone might just work i mean it sounds
like something from a cartoon but and i
understand the sausage was was not just
any old sausage it was actually cooked
in order for her to enjoy it fully i
mean i wonder if she managed to still
eat it whilst it was hot how did you
find someone to cook you a sausage
nearby
so
minnie had actually been out on the mud
flats for two nights by this point so we
were going into the third day of the
rescue and uh
the location we were in had uh attracted
the attention of the local residents who
were absolutely brilliant with the team
and you know they've been making cups of
tea and it was a local resident that
actually
cooked up the sausage for us brilliant
now we've been seeing images uh there of
people in kayaks and just explain to us
why those mud flats were so dangerous
for millie and why you weren't able to
reach her uh by boat or by foot
so the the area that she did it's um
yeah it is it's very dangerous and uh
local residents are all very familiar
with uh how dangerous the mother blacks
are and you know the the area itself can
look quite um you know even from the
pictures you can see it it almost looks
like it's it's possible to uh reach on
foot uh however the mud
will you will go straight up to your
waist uh so whilst we had tried attempts
to uh actually reach the motherflats and
get her on foot um you know she's much
lighter than than us humans she's
actually the whippet jack russell cross
and so she's she's much lighter on foot
and so she didn't think but certainly uh
we would have done and it just it
wouldn't have been possible for us to
actually uh get onto the mud flats where
she was yeah and then of course with the
tide uh rising she suddenly would have
found herself under uh water how long
did she have before the tide would have
would have potentially taken her away
so we'd spoken to the local coast guard
and
you know they're very familiar and
experts on the tide in the area and he
told us that whilst the area she was on
hadn't submerged at this point
as the days progressed uh the longer she
was there the the greater the risk that
the uh area would be submerged and sadly
she would either be sort of flushed out
to see or drown you know
an outcome that we just we couldn't bear
to think about so
we knew that time was against us and
yeah the longer she was there the
greater that risk yeah and of course
this uh story ended happily thankfully
uh even if a very uh in a peculiar way
let's just say
um
when you had that sausage dangling on
the end of the drone i don't know if it
was you who was actually operating it
that must have tested the operators uh
skills uh probably the first time
they've had a sausage dangling off and
you could see it kind of moving to and
fro was that something they'd been
prepared for how did you test that out
um you know what i think it was a case
of we are
at the you know
it's a last resort we need to we've
thought of everything else and and we
just need to give it a go um you know
our drone pilots are all experts um i'm
sadly not one of those i'm more of a
grounds person um but um you know
they're very experienced with the drones
um the the biggest risk that we actually
had in getting the sausage out really
was the fact that you know she'd been
out there for two
two days going into the third day she's
a hungry dog um and it was a tasty
sausage so she did take a bite and um
yeah our biggest concern was that she
was gonna carry on eating the sausage
and pull the drone down into the water
which thankfully she didn't do oh my
goodness i hadn't even thought of that
well thank goodness you didn't do that
and now you have another method
potentially for a future hungry pet
rescue sarah kane thank you so much for
being with us
thank you for having me